all right uh you're probably wondering
what new could be happening at the
border well some disturbing developments
we just want to bring you right up to
date on a bill of Illusion at Eagle Pass
with more hey Bill
Neil good afternoon to you believe it or
not today was one of the busiest days we
have seen in recent memory out here in
Eagle Pass we had two absolutely
enormous groups crossed this morning at
the exact same time let's get right to
the video and we'll show you the first
group take a look at this Drone footage
shot by our amazing flight team out here
in the Eagle Pass area this is a single
enormous group of several hundred
migrants Crossing illegally into
Normandy a little town on the outskirts
of Eagle Pass and as you can see they
are stretched out in a line almost as
far as the eye can see it seems like
they're predominantly single adults
being escorted by the Texas National
Guard and border patrol to a processing
area we saw several of these migrants
actually on their smartphones FaceTiming
people excitedly as they were crossing
illegally into the Texas area then take
a look at this video our drone team shot
as that group really started to gather
around and wait for processing ended up
being a group of well over 300 migrants
I had a chance to talk with a lot of
them as they were coming in many of them
telling me there were from Cuba
Nicaragua and the Dominican Republic
some of the Cubans told me they were
planning on going to Miami to link up
with family and those countries I just
mentioned for the most part are not
subject to title 42 meaning instead of
being expelled to Mexico a lot of the
people you see in this video here are
going to be released into the United
States after they're done being
processed and you might notice there's
no border patrol buses immediately on
scene in that video that is because
there was an even bigger group being
processed across town in Border Patrol
resources were over there take a look at
this video we shot at the exact same
time as that Normandy group was being
processed this was across town in Eagle
Pass what was left of an even bigger
group of well over 400 migrants who
crossed at the same time as you can see
from that video a majority of them also
single adults predominantly single adult
men in a short time before we started
recording this footage sources tell us a
48 year old Cuban woman actually went
into cardiac arrest and collapsed
shortly after Crossing and she died on
the scene right there and and these huge
groups that you see are a massive strain
on Border Patrol resources we saw some
migrants simply walking down a local
Highway with no border patrol to be seen
anywhere earlier today because again
agents can't be everywhere at once when
these huge groups are coming across and
back out here live when we talk about
these large groups border patrol
technically defines a large group as 100
or more migrants and listen to this stat
just since October 1st just here in this
Del Rio sector border patrol says they
have already encountered more than 50 of
these large groups here in this sector
again one sector one month happening
multiple times a day Neil we'll send it
back to you and 50 such groups at that
staggering bill malusion in Eagle Pass
thank you